torino fine anni 90 sono le quattro un
porto di pomeriggio e il made 15 anni fa
ea scuola probabilmente a far finta di
ascoltare la maestra tanto non so voi ma
io entrava scuola alle 8 e uscivo alle
quattro e mezza e so che non tutte le
scuole lo facevano il tempo pieno ma
alla mia sisma ovviamente otto
interminabili ore di studio scambi di
figurine panini dei calciatori 97 98 tra
l'altro album mai completato green di un
imbarazzante cibo della mensa che se
usati per stoccare le pareti e ma va
bene uguale come dicevo sono le quattro
un quarto e manca un quarto d'ora alla
fine della classe e la mente di tutti i
maschietti vale la stessa direzione
le casse di tartarughe ninja o da pura
liberi dio fa scadere l'apocalisse dal
cielo ma alle 5 dove di essere sul
divano con una brioche il male
sintonizzato su italia 1 e c'è sempre un
tuo compagno favela ciò che piangendo ti
diceva e ho capito ma io fino alle 6
sono a casa di mia nonna fare i compiti
e le cia la televisione che non prende
mediaset [ __ ] stronzo sui fuori dal
gruppo perché eravamo molto comprensivi
all'epoca quei 40 minuti perché erano
sempre due puntate di fila ci avevano
inconsapevolmente introdotto nel mondo
delle serie tv pensateci sedersi sul
divano guardare la puntata telefonava il
vostro amico per dirgli porca eva l'hai
vista aspettare comunque il giorno dopo
per parlarci di persona dirvi cosa vi è
piaciuto e cosa non vi è piaciuto a
insultare chi non l'ha ancora vista e ho
capito ma io fino all'eccesso da casa di
mia nonna fare i conti antonio e porca
di una [ __ ] nessuno sta parlando
conferma bene non sono cose che fate
ancora adesso
c'erano per un paio di inquietanti
misteri il mistero del ma quando cazzo
finisce st serie e il mistero del ma
qualcuno l'ha mai vista la prima puntata
si narravano leggende di qualcuno che
era riuscito a registrarla ai tempi in
una videocassetta tra non la prima
comunione un battesimo ma secondo me
sono tutte fandonie lo dicevano per
vantarsi con gli amici e quelle domande
che le pone vi perché da piccolo non ti
accorgevi della programmazione età
denuncia che facevano in tv ma ne
parleremo tra poco con il passare degli
anni aumentavano i canali
è progressivamente anche le serie per
citarne alcune i cavalieri dello zodiaco
su italia7gold konami ragazzo del futuro
su telesubalpina la balena giuseppina
sul canale 34 lo conosco solo io la
balena giuseppina lo immaginavo e
iniziavamo a guardare anche i primi veri
e propri telefilm supercar le in
baywatch che ha portato un intera
generazione a chiudersi in bagno a
perdere diottrie grazie fame.la grazie e
anche qui si iniziava notare qualcosa
che non andava nella programmazione
delle puntate ma ripeto ne riparliamo
più tardi la mia prima vera e propria
serie televisiva è stata i files per la
prima volta è riuscita a guardare una
serie dalla primissima puntata della
prima stagione alle nove di sera in
prima serata quindi subito dopo il
telegiornale e aveva quel particolare
che ti faceva capire che sarebbe stata
una grandissima figata
il bollino rosso è il bollino rosso
voleva di due rom e violenza e tette ma
le tette non erano mai altrimenti i
nostri genitori non ce l'avrebbero fatta
a guardare perché si sarebbe creato
quell'imbarazzo madre padre e figlio che
manco nel medioevo
sapevi mai se cambiare canale o no io
affascinato guardo ogni singola
magnifica puntata di questa serie fino
al finale di stagione con che cazzo e il
finale di stagione
nessuno prima mi aveva detto che i
telefilm sono divisi per stagioni e
quando finisce una stagione devi
aspettare dei mesi per guardare quella
dopo
ma voi volete uccidermi però questo mi
dava tempo di cercare un'altra serie per
coprire il buco di quella lì e poi
quando finiva quella di cercare un'altra
e poi un'altra ancora e poi un'altra
ancora e poi la pirateria
eh sì perché parallelamente si stava
sviluppando internet che stava entrando
nelle case degli italiani senza manco
bussare alla porta
vabbè adesso pirateria e la parola
perché per scaricare 3 merda di immagini
di dragon vuole mettere sul flop di
dover prendere un giorno di vacanze
avere un modem a 56k era come essere a
due metri da quello che avresti sempre
voluto dalla vita muovendo
56 mm allora il futuro
piano piano però internet diventato
sempre più veloce è relativamente più
economico ed insieme lui anche la
pirateria di voi non potete immaginare
le camionate di roma comprata legalmente
che girava tra me ei miei amici
tonnellate di quintali di dvd vergini
stuprati da serie tv cartoni animati e
film
ancora oggi ma le dico chi scriveva il
contenuto dei dvd con i pennarelli del
discount che ogni volta che li prendevo
con le mie mani coperti visto lutto
cancellato tutto e mi ritrovavo a casa
con vagonate appunto di vvd su cui non
avevo idea di cosa ci fosse dentro ma
vabbè ma internet è stato anche la
consapevolezza di un'agghiacciante
verità anche le tartarughe vince erano
divise per stagioni [ __ ]
questo vuol dire che tutto quello che ho
visto per anni non serve a nulla perché
erano tutte spadellate le puntate mi
tocca ricominciare da capo
magari dopo i 20 anni che manco mi
piacciono più le tartarughe ninja
ecco spiegato perché a volte c'erano
puntate che si ripetevano puntate nuove
con puntate vecchie o addirittura un
finale di stagione e l'inizio della
stagione dopo tutte e due nello stesso
giorno allora non ero io così stupido da
non aver mai visto la prima puntata è il
non aver mai visto la fine di una serie
sono viste tutte in volte probabilmente
senza saperlo questo perché molto
probabilmente perché le reti nazionali
ai tempi usavano i cartoni animati come
spazzatura per coprire i buchi del
palinsesto e non solo all'epoca è perché
io mi ricordo qualche anno fa quando
guardavo one piece in tv o ancora i
tempi quando lo guardavo in tv e quella
cazzo di serie di thriller bar clos
rivista 738 volte perché partiva la
serie arrivava a metà e poi
probabilmente per problemi logistici di
demo perché arrivavano che cazzo ne so
io vicino alla serie originale ottava lo
è lì cominciava mesi dopo ma non è che
ricominciava da dove si era fermato e no
è troppo semplice facciamo riprendere da
metà della serie prima così arrivi di
noi
chiave thriller bark arrivi a due
puntate dopo che tiri fermate di nuovo
di vermi e così vai avanti tu a dare la
colpa però ricominciando a river e sta
cazzo di seme di thriller bar ma basta
mamma dove nascondi le pillole per
dormire che deciderà ingozzare dove ma
dopo questo delirio dove voglio arrivare
voglio arrivare a dire che nonostante
tutto le serie tv sono forse molto più
incisive nella nostra vita di quel che
sembrano perché certo sono semplice tv
spesso anche spazzatura però a
differenza di un film per esempio la
serie che accompagna quando la seguì
regolarmente in una buona porzione della
tua vita
non voglio filosofeggiare a caso perché
ripeto è semplice televisione e non è
importante per le nostre esistenze ma ne
fanno parte ampiamente vi faccio un
esempio per farvi capire meglio quando
io ripenso a lost non ripreso soltanto i
personaggi alla trama ea quello che
succedeva durante le stagioni ma mi
viene in mente anche tutto quello che
succedeva a me quando io guardavo lost e
quindi gli ultimi anni di liceo tutti i
due che prendevo in disegno tecnico e
facevo il geometra che cazzo fa il
geometra che prendi due in disegno
tecnico sei un imbecille e come si
andasse a fa la scuola per cuochi non
sapessi fare un risotto alla milanese
per dire e tutto questo te ne accorgi
sembra si rifinisce non quando in corso
quando in corso non te ne accorgi ma
quando finisce vi prego perdonatemi il
paragone ma secondo me ci azzecca
abbastanza
e come quando un tuo amico si
trasferisce tuci scherzi chip all'ici
giochi tutti i giorni ma non ti rendi
conto di quanto fa parte integrante
della tua vita ormai e quando lui
prepara le valigie e se ne va col treno
a cagare in un paese chissà dove
e lì che ti colpisce la consapevolezza
che era molto più importante di quel che
sembrasse e così permettere film ma a
dire queste cose mi sento un idiota
quindi magari sono solo io poi ci sono
quelle volte rarissime per l'amor di dio
dove ogni tanto questo tuo amico ti
verrebbe tale gallo per terra come un
maiale sgozzarlo a testa in giù
riempirci la vasca a farci in bagno
stritolarlo e buttarlo in una fossa che
quando tease minchia tutta la serie con
l'ultima puntata e non voglio fare nomi
e how i met your mother fucking male ma
quella sarà discussione per un'altra
volta quindi questo volevo dire era un
piccolo discorso che volevo fare da
tanto tempo e molto personale questa
cosa vi piace un po e lo so che questo
sproloquio sembra non essere andato da
nessuna parte
in val de è vero non è andato a nessuna
parte ma in realtà erano solo una cosa
che mi piace mi sarebbe sempre piaciuto
dirvi e non trasformando la bella bella
a vela in un blog perché sanno ducoli
jonico lì ci si vede ora spetta prima di
andare via vorrei fare un piccolo
discorso però non così troppo informale
così sai cosa facciamo
prendiamo un bel cuscino ci sediamo sul
letto ci mettiamo seduti qua e parliamo
a messa sulle palle non le persone ma il
discorso che fanno alcune persone sul
tema i cartoni di oggi vanno tutti
cagare erano molto meglio ti insegnavano
molte più cose quelli nostri valle come
adesso ci sono alcuni cartoni che fanno
cagare e altri cattoliche sono bene o
male accettabili con argomenti anche
abbastanza seri prima c'era una cartoni
con argomenti seri e cartoni che
facevano pagare dovrebbero metterci
l'adesivo in testa diffidate da chi dice
e ina mastri cartai euro tutti molto
belli quelli ad esso fantastica gara
perché non hanno visto mezzo di quelli
nuovi
o non li hanno visti tutti e ripeto il
discorso dei nostri erano più belli ma
non è vero mycare mututi belli qualcuno
di voi hanno visto recentemente le
tartarughe ninja
la serie originale ovviamente vi è
familiare questa frase del papi che un
cartone da decerebrati che cazzo mi
significa un maiale che ti insegna le
cose che va con la famiglia più corto e
perché invece 4 tardi
rughe geneticamente modificate che
imparano le arti marziali da un topo che
prima era un maestro e si è trasformato
in un topo per delle scorie radioattive
che abitano nella merda delle fogne e
che mangiano pizza e non ti insegnano un
culo invece è morto meglio quando e
quante cazza facebook era un mezzo così
potente si è trasformato in o che puoi
andare a puntare a mare a dire che i
cartoni arrivati che adesso sono brutti
perché c'è peppa pig è perché c'è d'ora
dove il pallone è la mente carta
migliaia dei cartoni di merda non so se
avevate la coda di paglia vi sentivate
attratti da questo cartone qua ma credo
che il range d'età
per cui questo che questi cartoni sono
stati fatti sono da 0 a 1 devo
inversioni universitari di 25 e 26 anni
che andate a dire che per capire la
merda molto probabilmente è perché non è
per voi è come se nella nostra
generazione andassero dire i cartoni
animati fan cariare perché fa cagare
l'orso barroso
oppure frankie's a lasciarsi le scarpe e
sa contare fino a dieci non ho mai
sentito nessuno che li vedi savon per il
caxxo nell'orecchio di m ma guarda io so
contare fino a 15 lui fino a 10 che
cartone di merda e ma questo era un
piccolo sfogo personale in appendice ad
un video che parlava di serie tv in
generale quindi grazie mille per avermi
ascoltato come al solito e arrivederci
ma io so contare fino a 15 spero che tu
muoia nella lava